uh let's talk a little bit about
something we've discussed quite a bit
over the last three to four months
i've been talking to you
about the growing rift
within the republican party this sort of
civil war as we're calling it which has
mostly been trump republicans versus
slightly less bonkers republicans people
like liz cheney
adam kinzinger
mitt romney and some others and i've
also said before
the republican civil war is good for the
left the left should encourage it let's
help along the republican civil war
let's weaponize the republican civil war
against them to any extent that we can
we now have a new participant in this
civil war who seems to be trying to play
both sides we we've not seen this before
and i'm talking about republican
congressman dan crenshaw dan crenshaw
who has put out very confused takes
about socialism and different things he
seems smart enough to realize
that he needs to figure out a way to
play both sides on this republican civil
war
he is actually hugely pro-trump on
policy which is hilarious because it's
like what policy but okay during the
trump presidency crenshaw defended
trump's covet policy
totally abortive policy crenshaw
defended it trump said he liked trump's
economic policy uh crenshaw said he
liked trump's economic policy
but he's not big on the theatrics he's
not big on the cartoonish nuttery of the
writer at least not as big
well crenshaw spoke at the texas liberty
alliance and he did something that's
very interesting he trashed the
cartoonish pro-trump people
by saying they're grifters
they didn't actually vote
with trump as much as i did
i being crenshaw
and it's sort of like treading water so
check out this clip and now understand
that when crenshaw talks about the
freedom caucus he's talking about
marjorie taylor green mo brooks paul
gozar louis gohmert jim jordan those
types of cookie for cocoa puffs
republicans take a look supporting these
two
it's actually other veterans and
morgan's race
uh there's other front runners but why
support these two well because i've been
in congress for almost three years now
there's two types of members in congress
there's performance artists there's
legislators
now the performance artists are the ones
that get all the attention
but the ones you think are more
conservative because they know how to
say slogans real well
they know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear
let me tell you guys something in the
first two years of trump's presidency
when republicans were in control when
every single time we were voting on
donald trump's agenda
who do you think was at the top of that
list voting with trump and who do you
think was at the bottom
a lot of names you would recognize are
at the bottom of that list
a lot of names you would recognize are
at the top of that list
number two it's probably going to make
you cringe a little bit it's adam
kensinger
voted with trump almost 99
he was number two
but it was at the bottom
everybody in the freedom caucus
all of them
what you hear so often
is not true
it's not true
we have grifters in our midst
not here not like in this room that's
not what i mean
i mean in the conservative movement
lie after lie after lie because they
know something psychologically about the
conservative part
we're worried about what people are
going to do to do to us what they're
going to infringe upon us
so that is super interesting first of
all
crenshaw straight up says
these people
green and the her ilk these are
performance artists and grifters okay
fair
so crenshaw must be an anti-trump
republican right
wrong
he is criticizing them as grifters
because they perform and they do the
theatrics but at the end of the day
they are not actually pro-trump enough
in terms of how they vote
he says they should be more
truly pro-trump by actually supporting
more of trump's policies back while
donald trump was president and then he
says hey you know who does
adam kinzinger kinzinger is good so then
you might say if you've been following
the way the battle lines have been drawn
you might say wow
that's a big attack on the trump people
because among republicans
there's been no bigger critic of trump
than adam kinzinger right well no not
really because crenshaw is saying
kinzinger is good because he supports
trump more often than these freedom
caucus people based on voting so there's
three takeaways here and they're all
important number one
crenshaw is smart enough to recognize
the rift
and he's sort of trying to play both
sides for now because it's unclear what
the future of the republican party is in
2022 and 2024. is it a trumpian
republican party in the coming election
year and in 2024 or is it not so that's
one thing that he's doing number two
the civil war is real
and it should be encouraged because this
is exactly the type of confusion that
can create factions where republicans
damage themselves and we should welcome
that i mean to the extent that the left
is stinking it up
let's encourage the right to screw
themselves if we can and third and this
is really the key and i've told you this
before
the so-called anti-trump republicans liz
cheney adam kinzinger etc
they still mostly supported everything
trump did
they simply think joe biden won in 2020.
these are not our friends these are
still republican nuts
who accept the election results
liz cheney accepts trump did something
wrong with ukraine
but still voted with trump almost all
the time and what's happened is that the
bar has been so lowered
that it can be tricky to remember these
are still extremists right if liz cheney
is basically dick cheney politically
we saw dick cheney accurately as a
neocon kook when he was the vice
president
liz cheney more or less under the same
republican umbrella as dick cheney
now seems so much more reasonable
because she said trump lost the bar is
so low that they say one or two things
that are true and we go these are good
people these are not our friends these
are not our allies and let's not get
confused and believe that they are we're
gonna have more on this and you can send
us your comments
on our instagram find us at
davidpakmanshow on instagram and if you
want to see a really wacky hate mail i
got yesterday uh follow me on instagram
david.pakman
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too right now chili sleep is
running a special sale you'll get 30 off
everything when you go to
chilisleep.com pacman the link is right
underneath this video